Now that there's a new Black Panther on the scene,
the balance of power in the MCU is about to
change — in more ways than you might think.
The official trailer for Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever teased it, and the movie has no problem
confirming it: There's a new Black Panther
in town, and her name is Shuri. However,
this is not the playful, happy-go-lucky Shuri
that fans might remember from Black Panther.
Much like her predecessor and brother T'Challa,
she goes through a great deal of loss and sorrow
before fully embracing her role as Wakanda's
protector. Not only does T'Challa himself
die unseen in the early stages of the movie,
but Wakanda Forever antagonist Namor's attack
ends up killing her mother, Queen Ramonda.
Shuri starts the movie in denial over the
spiritual world and the Black Panther tradition,
preferring to focus on science instead. However,
Ramonda's death and the impending threat of
Namor's Talokan forces cause her to return to
an old project: an artificial recreation of
the Heart-Shaped Herb. With the help of her
old research, T'Challa's DNA, and a gift from
Namor, Shuri manages to create a new version
of the plant that gives Black Panthers
their powers — and promptly uses it.
Up until now, the Heart-Shaped Herb
has been treated as a highly unique
commodity that was lost forever when
Killmonger destroyed the remaining crops.
"Burn it all!"
Now that Shuri has figured out a way to replicate
the precious plant, however, it might have a
huge impact on the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Judging by how Shuri manages to go toe-to-toe with
Namor in the finale, it seems that her artificial
Heart-Shaped Herb is comparable to the original,
and seems to be at least as potent as the other
prominent superpowered substance in the MCU:
Abraham Erskine's Super Soldier Serum, which
famously turns Steve Rogers into Captain America.
As it happens, the Super Soldier Serum is a huge
deal in the MCU. For decades, scientist after
scientist and nation after nation has tried to
replicate the effects of Erskine's serum, after
the original recipe was lost with Erskine himself.
The results of these often dubious experiments
have ranged from Red Skull and the Abomination
to U.S. Agent and the Flag Smashers. So imagine
what will happen when the world finds out that
Wakanda is sitting on a substance that can make
people at least as powerful as Captain America.
The day the world discovers the existence of
Shuri's Heart-Shaped Herb could be nearer than
you'd think, too, because there's one person
outside Wakanda who already knows about it.
Though Riri Williams doesn't witness the entire
process of recreating the Heart-Shaped Herb,
she is present during Shuri's ingestion ritual. As
such, she has a good idea of how the herb is used,
and of the risks involved. What's more,
she specifically requests some for herself
after seeing its effects on Shuri.
While that line about wanting to try
the herb herself is played as a joke, Wakanda
Forever establishes Riri as a highly intelligent
person with an inquisitive mind. If her rather
obvious gadgeteer genius parallels with Tony
Stark continue, it would be almost surprising
if she didn't end up tinkering with a version
of the recipe, or using her connection with
Shuri to learn more about the new Heart-Shaped
Herb. She might even inadvertently reveal
its existence to somebody. If that happens,
or Shuri's new Heart-Shaped Herb recipe
gets out of Wakanda in some other way,
the MCU could be looking at a whole new generation
of super soldiers running around the block.